guys before the video starts i'm doing a
winter appeal for syria afghanistan and
ethiopia probably sisters inshallah
people are literally freezing we will
never live in those conditions help me
reach my target to give them some walk
i've done the seven-day free trial of
the quranic app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated download it and see what time
it is
assalamualaikum guys hope you guys are
wearing inshallah so before i start the
video bro my sisters i want to tell you
guys the video that i did about saudi
selling pork the brother in question uh
with the voice not going contact me and
told me there was a miscommunication
between him and the waiter and that
saudi is not selling pork whatsoever and
my video was about that anyways you know
it was about that just because you hate
someone doesn't mean you know you should
believe everything that comes through so
just to clarify that inshallah but
talking about saudi arabia again now as
you guys know now the virtual reality um
the metaverse has entered our
realm should we say and now subhanallah
um is coming to the point where um
we are scared you know we are thinking
are we going to end up these people
going to end up going hajj going to
jummah
visiting the holy masjids via the
metaverse the virtual reality well in um
saudi arabia arabia
has actually
done the opening of this uh very thing
uh this concept and hamdulillah as you
guys know problems this is any action to
be accepted in our religion there has to
be two conditions number one the
intentions have to be there your
intentions have to be
uh that you are doing this action for
the sake of allah the second one is that
it has to be according to the prophetic
sunnah the prophetic tradition so if any
of those are missing it's not accepted
so i can't say i'm gonna go to a club
and give dawah when it doesn't fit the
prophetic tradition because there's my
intention in the right place but you
know that's not gonna you know it's not
gonna be a good idea and secondly is if
you do the actions but there's no
intention so if somebody might be
wearing a hijab for the rest of their
life but the intention is not for the
sake of allah it's profession you're not
going to get rewarded the both things
have to be there so i very highly doubt
even though chef today is open this and
it can be something that you know can be
some kind of an experience whatever it
may be i doubt it would ever match the
real thing
but it's still a bit like you know and
this video is not to criticize the
kingdom
but it's just like it's getting a bit
scary in the context of everything the
metaverse virtual reality what i know if
it's going on are we going to be giving
down soon with these virtual reality
things uh you know we're going with this
vr and we're going to wear it and you
know
travel go to speaker squad like then
give dawah we don't know what the future
holds up we ask allah to protect us and
yes we should be up to date
and see you know using the current
memphis technology whatever it is to do
dawah but sometimes we have to be
careful but what was it a little bit um
i was so concerned about shaykh so they
said that um the experience should not
be just visually and
by audio it should also be
the smell he said something along those
lines which you can see uh subhanallah
brother sisters um yeah i think maybe
just one experience is good but i just
wanted to give you guys um this news
subhanallah which is actually unfolding
you know we started with mark zuckerberg
the meta verse and now this
inshallah we ask allah to protect us and
hopefully it's just something a means of
just us you know a bit of fun but then
again subhanallah we're going to be
fully disconnected now supporting our
people going to speak to each other via
via vr and japan next thing we know that
when we take out vr and we see vaginas
already here
maybe uh swan alabama sisters that's i'm
not going to hold you guys along until
next time around sisters take care and
look after yourself may allah bless
every single one of you guys please do
not forget i'm doing a winter appeal
with muslim aid to help raise funds for
people in syria afghanistan and ethiopia
it's freezing cold broken sisters we
could never live in those conditions
please give what you can assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh